et madame philippe de faire entrer le
deuxième masse clover on a une deuxième
surprise pour quelqu'un autour de la
table je vous le dis j'ai été très très
très étonné de devoir faire appel à
cette personne je n'ai rien vu arriver
tout comme vous chez vous vous n'avez
certainement rien pourtant regardez le
premier indice
et vous qu'on puisse avoir le coup de
foudre en direct à la télévision est-ce
que vous pensez que l'un d'entre vous
ici que le coup de foudre en direct à la
télé jean-louis week est pas moi
benjamin benjamin oui avec votre note la
vie oui mais je vous parle dernièrement
mais moi je pose des questions réponses
si on n'a rien vu en tout cas si elle a
par jamie je dirais chevelure
d'artichaut c'est vrai que je me suis
assez sensible
donc c'est vrai que je suis célibataire
et je peux tomber très vite amoureux
mais et pour celle avec une idée
impensable c'est la vie ça m'a mise
mamie réveille toi il faudrait pour
votre mari vous avez un coup de fouet
vous l'avez vous jouez vous l'avez vu
comme ça passait avant je n'ai pas vu
jouer moi bah voulez vous non je n'ai
rencontré sur ce match est non fort va
lui aussi rencontrer sa meuf sur
snapshots et fo snap shot
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
une boîte à ça tout les serristes
regarder le 2 0 de passe selon vous
l'amour et la politique sont compatibles
propos est-ce que selon vous la
meilleure et la politique sont
compatibles ouais bah ouais tu nous dire
voilà une fois de plus ce masque lover
vous concerne
il ya quelque chose qui est ce que je
les ai vus je les ai vus c'est vrai
malaise qu'elle avait déjà le même
pantalon
j'arrive pas avec la personne c'est
roselyne bachelot l'artichaut à trouver
des vinaigrettes l'artichaut est ce que
will qui je veux parler je crois que
cette semaine vous avez eu un coup de
foudre pour quelqu'un qui est venu nous
rendre visite dans touche pas oui vous
qui êtes avec nous bien ce jour michel
mr a eu un coup de foudre pour quelqu'un
oui je vais vous montrer des images et
la personne viendra nous rejoindre juste
après à vous allez voir jean-michel il
est quand même terrible je ne vais plus
amené d'invités dont l'un est bien dans
l'avion va voir si c'est bien la
personne qui est venu nous voir et elle
vous donnera sa réponse en direct c'est
oui s'il vient c'est oui je prendrai mes
fils rare fois le serveur amène le
mauvais plan
mardi pour le deuxième tour se faire ça
pour moi c'est génial problèmes de santé
auxquels ils adorent le ballon je vais
changer
[Musique]
youpi l'accueil de ces travaux le soir
[Applaudissements]
échaudés de belles choses ce soir à mon
match le shérif qui coanime avec moi je
me régale avec toi mais moi si mon bébé
je prenne le sommet ça veut dire que si
par hasard ça se fait qu'ils arrivent à
partir sur btp lui non on va louer à
partir tout simplement à l'ovale voisins
elle valoir
je voudrais remercier tu es députés
laurence baudet adjointe au maire de
levallois au service des sports à
belleville être avec nous à croire
[Applaudissements]
on comprend quand michel parce que l'on
range bourdes et elle est magnifique
c'est très très laurence bourdais est
belle laurence bourdais est intelligente
laurence bourdais et souriante leur
grosse bourde est sympathique mais
laurence bourdais et marié m est elle
venue qu'est ce qu'elle a elle est
mariée et a détaillé bible je n'ai rien
entendu
ça c'est la douche froide laurange
bourdais vous êtes venu mais vous êtes
marié quoi oui je voudrais lui témoigner
d'ailleurs ce sens est depuis dix ans
pour la peine on attendait chez les
médecins
les médecins et sauve des vies massif et
benji et je voulais lui dire ce soir que
je les aime beaucoup et je vais
maintenant on croyait que sa lettre la
soirée de l'amour pour l'instant fatou
qui n'appelle pas il prend une banane en
direct m la soirée du cauchemar
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis content moins morose est
magnifique vous aviez vraiment craqué
pour le oui j'ai craqué pour elle mais
je suis ravi de savoir qu'elle est très
heureuse dans son couple évidemment que
personne avait craqué pour moi je suis
pas aussi je suis agent secret ah oui ça
m'a fait vraiment plaisir ça m'a pris
j'ai quand même temps 15 ans n'en
tiendra quatre questions bien sûr et
vous n'êtes pas du tout aux couples est
libre maintenant ayalon je sais pas moi
non je vais vous poser une question
qu'est née des associateurs se pose bien
entendu que nous sommes dans direct
sourire c'est l'amour et l'amour et
parfois dangereux ovo benger partout car
tous les actes laurence way serait ce
que par l'opération du saint-esprit
ou bien tu nous étions dans dans la
fiction
ouais et bizarrement du jour au
lendemain vous retrouver célibataire est
heureuse dans ma carrière parce que
voilà vous avez envie d'être libre free
free dom présent sans sucre peuvent avec
calme toi toi tu es né en faut un par
mois n'est pas de conneries il ya les
infos sont sous marine non pas du tout
répond pas aux appels de son mari va
très bien je connais pas mon ibook très
bien lancé ce que jean-michel aurait pu
être votre style un tout à fait
[Applaudissements]
c'est par laurence et bien écoutez
merci là c'est comme si il ya quelqu'un
qui vient de te dire il a fait dire
écoute tu sais quoi
tu avais des bons numéros du loto monde
a perdu le ticket celle ci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les séries est très gentil devenue la
salle amour elle est belle c'est une
femme comme ça qu'ils jugent pourtant
qu'elles soient heureux c'est une femme
comme ça qui lui tape sur les classes de
caractère comme ça avec une une année
dit il mais moi quelque chose à la une
rome est serré du croquant